I'm Theo von welcome to another episode
of allegedly with my co-host Matthew
Cole Weiss hello there and today we have
a special guest it's the way you said
special makes me feel like I must be
cognitively impaired that's where it
started as far as I know big words yeah
dr. drew is here with us dr. Drew Pinsky
thank you for joining us brother you
back yeah we're excited to have you and
Matt did you explain the the way we
break yeah how did no I got it you gotta
break down so and you and I know each
other from the atom and dr. Drew show we
do and thank you guys so much for having
and thank you for filling in for me I'm
going out of town for a couple weeks
yeah I'm a little nervous oh he's good
to everybody except me and Bruce okay
we're happy to be here today we're gonna
start with our round one yes you're
gonna be the judge
Matt is there a scale for my judging or
based on whatever criteria you want
it's freeform everything a free-form you
can you can award points left and right
if you want is there or duct is there
something for the winner something for
the loser HT or - no there's no way
chase Matt wait a lot I think because we
bring in a lot of guests that kind of
paid that kind of pandering cater to
some of his nature's what does that mean
what am i name like a lot of liberal
guests let's say that well your
pandering for a vote right now I'm not
pairing it all just by saying that all
subliminal messaging apparently he's
very manipulative oh I know I might be I
don't know if I am or not yes all right
round one at three minutes on the clock
all right I'll go first so this is kind
of a hygienic story but it's also kind
of something out of character for me
because I do suffer from some kind of
like germophobia of a sorts like I do
not like Howie Mandel bad but like I've
always had issues with it I don't have
pets for that reason like I just can't
so I went to South Africa on a trip with
my brother and we were on Safari which
was really cool and you're in this you
know the truck and you're driving around
and you with all these other people who
come from different places world we were
with a bunch of people from
England well the non-european England
now um I don't like British but go on
who have gone on safari many times so
there's an animal called a kudu which is
kind of like an antelope sort of thing
and they poop yeah it's not a racial
slur okay good no it's not racial slur
okay
they poop like kind of like like pellet
like kind of like ball bearing sort of
things like little pellets kind of like
paintballs like a duck like bigger
rabbit poop and so they told us this is
this British family that what they do
everytime they come is they have like a
watermelon seed spitting contest but
with the kudu poop you put the poop in
your mouth and you spit it as far as you
can and whoever wins wins and so this is
like I've had some things in my mouth
but never anything fecal really okay
good it's good to know actually probably
fecal Jason but never anything fecal rim
fecal yeah they're actually no I think
about it alright so anyway so I was I
was disgusted but also and you know
curious to see we can learn something to
bring back to West Hollywood that's a
new bar game yeah exactly
I've been practicing na so my brother
was with me and he we all did it and we
put it in our mouths and I had time yeah
one at a time and then the first time I
did it when I kind of like like tried to
spit it out it kind of like crumbled in
my mouth so it's definitely like and I
was like but then by then I was so
committed and everyone was like go go go
so I had to pick up another poop put it
in my mouth and spit it out I didn't win
the contest but I did it and I was so
paranoid for I'd say the next two days
that I had caught like I don't know zika
or ebola or something cuz I'm sure
there's stuff and poop that's not good
yeah like like poops not supposed to be
in your mouth but yeah that's something
very out of character however you see
what dogs do with it yes that I stay
away from them that's a party snack for
them so I had poop and Mama
well I always knew kind of knew you
didn't I'm that far for the winning
stick it was the the the the British
they they can spit their poop pretty far
was a guy who looked like a bulldog it
was a it was a woman it was the mom who
spitted the best like she she kind of
like you know did the whole like her
body went backwards
in hell and she spit it out far and I
mean I mine was kind of like like the
old lady from Titanic throwing the thing
in the water you know that's really what
my poop was like it was like wow okay
Drew Pinsky is tabulating over here all
right you're dumb well interestingly
enough dude I actually brought a feces
story you know shadow I am not even
joking I'm not even joking it's you dr.
Dre this you can't wait bring the poop
out of us so years ago I got into the I
got invited to a sometimes you get
invited to like celebrity golf term for
celebrity things like that I'm sure you
go to a ton of those do you play golf no
no did you see a picture of you with
Goldie Hawn at a oh yeah that's pretty
cool oh yeah she's awesome yeah so uh I
got invited to this Randy Moss
Invitational fishing tournament right
and this is when he played for the
Minnesota Vikings Randy Moss is a
African American football player Matt
doesn't do anything about that he thinks
Randy Moss is probably like a new color
of tree that they're offering at Sherwin
way there Adam put him up or any monster
picture next to like there was some baby
dinosaur looked exactly thank you from
that show the dinosaurs probably
claymation dinosaurs like more like a
puppet kind of thing I know exactly the
hairstyle that he probably had in the
one you're talking about so it was a
fishing rodeo and there were some unique
celebrities there like Roy Jones jr. was
there the other famed boxer a lot of
football players Lindsay Lohan actually
was sleeping in the hotel room across
from me I actually put a note under her
door no you did not
god I did I was like if you want to hang
out like I'm staying across the hall and
kind of
some guy right she never hit me up and
out this is during the time you know
like maybe this is when she was into the
women yeah yeah it was going on but
anyway so fast-forward we go out to this
fish and Rodeo and I grew up fishing but
like fishing from the bank you know we
didn't have a boat you know saying we're
not going out in the water dude you know
we're not gonna risk drowning to get the
fish and you can get him from the side
so we uh so next you know you're with a
professional angler and with a sponsor
so you're out on the boats you have to
get there like 5:30 in the morning and I
sit up partying they had a party the
night before and it was like a basically
a bunch of brothers just parading around
their white girlfriends right and it was
cool man I respect it you know like if I
was her banana Nath Lee I would
definitely have a beautiful white
girlfriend right but I'm not I'm just a
basic white man and so I don't get that
privilege okay so anyway moving forward
we got white privilege does not include
the white girl anymore
okay not anymore dude I'm hustlin
thicker Persian girls over in West V
okay and I'm babysitting the Bichons to
prove it
they all have a bichon okay but anyway
moving forward so we partied late the
night before man and I was really really
drunk got up in the morning you have to
be there like 6:30 I get to the boat
launch and next thing you know the like
alright go all the boats take off we're
out there about a half hour like when do
we go back and the guys like oh we're
out here for about five hours five hours
bro and I can just feel my bowels just
fist-fighting you know they're just like
others getting Randy and just real fired
up cuz we're talking to number two you
had yeah I'm talking about or two right
and I can I can't I had to stop fishing
because if I jerk the thing I literally
was gonna just blow out of my rear right
so at some point I'm like I have to go
to the bathroom guys and like I'll just
pee off the back we'll look the other
way right so I have these two thicker
white guys or my teammates look in the
other way and I don't have to pee you
know so I literally just took my pants
off and left him on the boat while these
dudes are looking our way and like laid
in the water like held onto the boat
just went to the bathroom investor does
this the the money man he won man and he
turn around and look
you can hear some of the kind of come to
the surface a little log fish it was
chumming up yeah and he looked back it
was literally just just passing the book
right I'm feeding the fish and that's it
I still don't catch a fish into the bar
stories neither of us won like we're
both losers in our stories you are both
losers but moat one must win today yes
today and that's my time before you pick
a winner I did want to happen during no
no I want to know what is the worst
possible thing that could happen to me
for him having poop in my mouth I don't
know of anything from kudu kudu is like
oh yeah buddhu that's way it's exotic
but I can't think of anything most of
the trouble is human yeah okay so what's
the worst thing you happen if you have
human poop horrible I mean that's that's
the leading means whereby infections
days are transmitted the so called oral
fecal root in a certain country what
country would it be anything to end do
to do the best yes there are way really
probably the more north the better maybe
maybe even a pride Norway why because
the chill of the environment would it's
I I don't know they have less of that
stuff it's more as you go towards the
warmer climates at that stuff I think
it's more that the has to it the sewage
system or anything else just seen all
the scene Florida probably any good
place but the point is not comment up
there so you're not going to get the
Norway well I got a pic right yeah you
got to pick a winner ever so very well
done gentlemen
I laughed I cried there was a very tough
fought I thought that the unique quality
of Matt's story immediately caught my
attention but then the build-up Theo on
yours
dropping a little Lindsay Lohan yeah no
celeb jumping yes I don't know that
happen or not but I was all in there
then and and by the way it got a little
racist but you sort of redeemed yourself
with a Persian girl so okay yeah I was
sort of uncomfortable for a minute there
I almost almost well I know you I'm
always uncomfortable or though so he
labeled the white guys and the
african-american guys so for some reason
equal equal his racism applies all races
including white yes exactly
I understand his white privilege that's
good where that but ultimately because
it's a these are both whose stories it's
got to go poo poo right I have to
measure the Pooh stories against one
another is about the poo here and then
you guys set it up that way
unfortunately because because you were
in with the buildup right but when you
go poo to poo yeah you win because kudu
poo I had a knee through in the little
little details like the poo crumbling in
his mouth that was it oh yeah the
Titanic moment so you got that detail
too I cut just amazing it he wins all
the time with the war stories they're
not the worst stories they are they with
your hearts just stay with your parties
all right let's move on to round 2 which
is our interview segment war we'll take
turns asking you questions you are in
the hot seat
being the judge yeah and you're gonna
yeah and you can pick who's a better
interviewer at the end that's really
based on whatever you want now my first
question is and you kind of hinted at
this before we start recording but do
you get sick and tired of people asking
you look at this for me what's wrong
with me
no I don't I actually don't there's
there's sort of two answers that I have
to give you on this is that I love
people and I love interacting with
people so in a very and if I can be of
service and actually make a difference I
I can't get enough of that so I'm really
grateful that I have something that
makes a difference and it can really be
helpful to people the bad part is that
there's a structure to relationship with
a physician you know you
walk in there's a time period the doctor
walks out when you push me up against
the Abbas Abbas at a 7-eleven that's
never stopping there's no ad and if I
try to get away it's like Oh mr.
celebrity oh I see we go no no dude I've
been here for 20 minutes I might the get
there lined up behind my car began sir I
gotta go and so that's uncomfortable so
I try to avoid stuff because of the lack
of structure and what I was complaining
about was that if I ask for anything
from my audience particularly Ikon
Twitter mm-hmm fu
Wow go to hell you want you want me to
do what listen to your pocket go screw
you Wow and so somehow I get a pass when
I'm with Corolla cuz Corolla they'll do
anything he says right so when he says
you know support these sponsors though
yes sir yes sir you're with Crowell yes
serve God but if I were to ask on my own
no way so you're saying we should have
had Corolla on the show if you want to
make money that's how you what's the
grossest thing that someone has
approached you up on like on the street
and said hey will you look at this or I
shown you and shown you like do they I'm
sure that has happened and I and I can't
think of anything because I often I run
away from stuff like that that was so
severe you had to address it right then
Oh like save someone right there ah I'm
sure there has been there's been stuffs
happened you know people have run get me
and look come over here resuscitate this
guy you ever see like does giant goiters
like I'm sure oh they like calm on the
street like people coming up into it
well and my boy Dirk you can see them
across though well that's two quarters
really freaked me out no I wrote on it
just it thinks it reminds you side of
beauty they used to be called the big
die roid yeah no they did if you look at
some of these Renaissance or even
baroque era paintings it just makes me
think of like a twin that didn't develop
no no that's a nice picture the teeth in
the little and that's what it makes me
think of to be a mole that actually
looks like him a little bit that's like
yeah kinda looks like his face a little
bit it almost looks like another one
here was trying to come out
I think God shut it down I have a
question for you um so from like an
outsider's perspective and even having
gotten spent some time with you through
you you guys's podcast the admin dr.
Drew show do you seem like to have it
all put together you know in my life yes
you do
where does it where does that end like
where is the like where does it fall
apart over the place does it yeah sure
that's that's the thing I always find
myself saying like if something comes
out about me and people go I'm like no
I'm not a perfect human right I am NOT a
perfect um I don't claim to be a perfect
human being you don't claim nothing I
don't want to be perfect to me nor do I
judge other people about what their
things are I'm interested in helping
people that want help right that's it
and if they're help if it happens to
include you're out of control of the
substance or a behavior I'm happy to
help I don't care if they if they're not
I control they're enjoying those
behaviors they party on that's it yeah I
have no problem that but like I some
stuff came about me doing cocaine in the
80s yeah and yeah I was like yeah that
happened and was like I didn't talk
about it for a long time because I have
a rule that you don't discuss what you
did during your adolescence and young
adulthood when you have kids you don't
discuss it with your kids because they
will use that as a justification to
start where you left off oh wow and so
is that proven is that a document oh
yeah I've seen it a million times and so
my thing is always look we're not
discussing it you know and so when other
people Stern asked me once I was like
nah Tana but and I felt bad about it and
I oh man apology for that but I felt
justified because I'm protecting my kids
right now they're 24 years old out that
sorry kids I was not I'm not perfect but
I but but you want them not to be doing
these things you better not start with
don't lie to them don't lie to your kids
my grades don't ever lie to the kids but
if they ask just are not up we're not
discussing that's up for but it's
interesting that you do because there is
that anybody that has a totally
different impact then hey son when I
look at the spleef let spliff we did
back in my day right we sold it in lids
and it was compared with you guys have
you ever smoked with your no do you do
with them no I
concerns me it worries me yeah I I think
I got panic attacks from in college I
did yeah and and I and this stuff is so
strong these guys are you guys
everyone's doing now it scares the hell
I've been treating I would probably have
an adverse reaction and I've seen so
many bad reactions it and they're
getting worse now do you feel like
there's an issue with the fact that they
legalize marijuana
but that legalization was based on like
probably a different type of marijuana
than the stuff they're doing no no the
legalization is based on the desire of
the people and that's what the law
should be determined wise to some extent
and if that's what they want I think our
drug laws are sort of crazy Yeah right
alcohols good pots bad cigarettes or
heroines bad but Moxie cons good come on
there's a stupid laws but I just think
the people wanted to correct that and
now they're learning that it's not the
benign thing and that you know I'm here
to deal with the consequences I'll help
right I was gonna say it's interesting
because like one time I was at an event
and I saw dr. oz from not dr. oz dr. H
from The Biggest Loser
the guy who yeah yeah and he was
partying he's a good guy yeah he was
with Charlie Sheen and he was he had a
hot chick with her he was drinking and I
was like I had that kind of responsible
doctor age I'm not too cool to be with
she party that's true but but he's
entitled to go out and completely but
I'm feeling like if I saw you doing that
I would be a little like yeah if I have
a glass of wine people freaking and it's
like no no I'm not that no party guy
yeah I do I do a podcaster Duncan
Trussell is you know donkey yeah don't
really unique guy right and he and I
have a great relationship and we like
respect and try to understand each
other's points of view and stuff and
good on him I'm saying I don't care he's
an adventurer very such a energy so
smart Oh what is that what's that
podcast called the drunken trustful
family hour or something it's good no
I'm have to check it out so this is my
question so I looked up a couple of
other famous Drew's and I came up with
Nancy Drew
okay so I'm gonna read three Nancy Drew
book titles tell me which one is most
like your life
the mystery of the ivory charm the
whisper am I supposed to know what the
plots of these books are now okay just
don't think the whispering statue is the
haunted bridge I like all these the
mystery of the ivory John Ross - wrong -
the haunted bridge there's a doctor yeah
but I think there was more accurate as
coral I'm like a working with me as like
working with a cigar-store Indian he
would agree with the whispering statue
Wow I'm dry I like the idea of the
haunted bridge I'm attracted to it fair
enough which which kind of I mean that
those are good sort of little
personality yeah and that is me I am NOT
all what I appear to be I guess it's not
even appearance I think it's just your
nature and being a doctor is what being
a doctor being in that right yeah yeah
you don't see a doctor a lot of times in
the public eye as much and so that's a
unique experience it was when he again
it was a rough experience maybe because
because I was you know I started doing
this when I was like a intern like a
medical student actually and I really
you know wanted I did you know I've
totally bought into being the best
doctor and the best everything and if my
peers looked at me a little askance it
really bothered me but I was of the
public well that's why I didn't use my
last name I made up a name and right and
I didn't tell anybody I did it
but people caught wind of it eventually
and it's it's a it's an underling
stepping out of line saying under under
they shouldn't be doing that right but I
always felt like look I'm 24 and I know
what these seventeen girls are up to and
you guys don't know right and I need to
talk to him and that was in the early
days of AIDS we weren't even calling it
aids yet and I said four grids
gay-related intestine disease syndrome
and we had no causative agent then we
had the htlv three-member all that and
then we had the HIV htlv1 and in HIV and
it was it you know and he was in the
term safe sex I was talking about
condoms before that term was invented
Wow and condoms were still behind the
counter he still got them you know ask
the pharmacist to go pull them out with
the enemies oh absolutely
oh yeah and and I just thought it was
sort of important to do it I just
thought my instinct was yeah it would do
it and so I was forbidden for a while by
my residency director so I took out for
a while but I kind of drifted back and
then then that guy made me his chief I
was the chief of the whole operation and
then during that period he come up to me
goes he's doing that radio show I
remember used to do that how about I'll
do it now let's take it over for you I'm
like what did you did you set out
wanting to be no being Remus no like
famous or I mean you you do a lot of
shows and you've done a lot of shows
over the years and you were on wheel of
fortune oh well that was yeah that was
you see the tape on that I haven't seen
the tape I just I was on Ellen and and
she they ambushed me with that and she
goes how's it feel and I go well
everybody that was probably the thing I
feared most in life that that tape would
show up somewhat wasn't so bad face your
fears but that was because a friend of
my want a car on wheel of fortune I
managed I had a two week break between
medical school and internship and I
wasn't doing anything and I was like
well [ __ ] if that guy can win a car I
can do that I got my ass really
I auditioned for the show and then I
asked to buy an end and then that was it
but the real one against me bad as far
as the fame aspect of it do you do you
feel like people have questioned your
motives or anything ever through the
years but yeah always I think and I
think that's why I have to play very
nice you get clear about my own
motivation of what I'm doing why I do it
yeah and and and because it's it's a
there's a strange sort of navigation I
have to do which is I'm I'm here to make
a difference that's why I do it
and I'm so grateful that that's what I
do because I can't imagine a worse
reason to be here doing media then hates
me right like the rest of us you're
trying to peel laughs right and you have
and you have a craft and you have a
think musicians have a correct you know
the purpose and journalists have a
correct you know there's people have
crafts in media reality show
participants not so much that's dark
yeah it I'm so grateful to have a
purpose in doing it but we're all in
this entity where you have to exist
before you can do your job you know you
have to have like in other words like
people I'll go do movie roles once in a
while just to just to exist exist out
there as people go yeah that's that guy
oh I should listen it why should your
right because you have to do stuff to
kind of advertise it's kind of
advertising or just to live in the
landscape so people kind of remember you
and oh yeah this guy's got information
he says this guy so such as the upcoming
sharknado 4 right yeah well that was
fine
that was it yeah that was just sometimes
I'll do stuff just just to be part on
okay we'll just be part of culture for
fun or just to participate in culture as
long as it doesn't diminish anything but
yeah I mean your your your existence in
your path and Hollywood is so unique
because I mean medicine is such a
revered and even I'm sure like when you
were coming up with your saying your 20s
I mean a lot of those guys like the
older guys will look down upon the you
know I'm sure I was people just thought
I was bizarre
and I just one thing I learned by doing
that and trusting my instincts that
there was something important to be done
through media that was my even my naive
idea was that radio had been such a
negative influence on health maybe radio
could be a positive influence that was a
little sort of little idea I started
with and and because that was a pretty
clear and good instinct I don't question
young people's instincts anymore if they
have a clear and say just go with it
don't don't as if you're my age and
you're gonna question 24 olds instinct
at your own peril right you know because
they usually see and experience things
differently than people have been around
a long time picking up the radio so do
you miss Loveline no no I mean I I kinda
do but I but I'm so much healthier than
having REM sleep again and I feel so
much better that that compensates me I
miss miss my producer I miss my engineer
Missy and Mike more every day
I missed the callers I miss you know
being able to in real time interact but
we do some of that in the animal juice
right so what do you think someone wrote
in that they said Amber Rose said that
she was taking over a Love liner she was
bringing it back there doing something
yeah they're doing something like that
that eh wonder something it's been tried
a million times enjoy the good luck
it's it's a really specific thing and
people don't understand what it is so
right you see maybe someone that takes
advantage of your time like on this
planet and in existence what is a skill
that you feel like you would love to
learn but you don't think you're gonna
have the time a million things are there
what's one that really stands out there
I would say speaking a couple more
languages and and getting back on an
instrument piano yeah again really
bothers me that that there won't be time
for that specially the language thing
that matter for somebody lately has
really would bother me
yeah and I've read I mean online that
you're like a religious you don't have
much of a belief system religiously or
you just not like to discuss it no I
just I'm just sort of sort of agnostic
right now once you had children did that
adjust your belief because then I'm sure
you love your children so much that you
want to that it might alter your mindset
because you want to believe in like in
an afterlife or an environment Oh we'll
be able to see them again there's no
doubt in my mind that when I'm faced
with that kind of stuff I'll have to
retreat to those ideas to survive it
cultivating it in my day-in day-out life
it doesn't work for me doesn't do it you
know but but i but i know i I have
actually jealousy of people that have a
deep faith in that kind of thing right
it is very reassuring and I've I deal
with death and dying all the time as a
physician I mean people go there
internist to die that's that's a time I
learned early on in my training Wow and
so it doesn't you know once all the
oncologists are done and once the
specialists are done a certain are done
to hand you back the patient and they're
they're done fixing things there's no
more fixing yeah they just jump off the
ship and and so I deal with it a lot and
I know admired when people had a really
deep concept about that and maybe
they're right I don't know how do you
how do you cope with it with death dying
yeah like we face with it so much it's
it becomes a very concrete reality as
much as any other part of life and so to
me it becomes important to do it with
with dignity and purpose and the way
they live there should be the way they
die I see it as a very it can be a
glorious thing it's not fun it's not not
painful right and
sad for everyone that has a loss but you
you can you know young people dying I
say I'm not a pediatrician I couldn't
deal with the kids I could not deal with
it but you know you could you couldn't
even adults even otherwise healthy you
know young or middle-aged adults you you
could make purpose of things you have
you been the last person that people are
dying have spoken to have you had any of
that experience like people die right in
front of me yeah
Oh time is there I've got some strange
stories like that yeah I like what yeah
you know there are people even that I've
had to dial off the stuff that was done
the volume oh yeah that was really rough
because because I was working for
cardiologist I was it was a resident
then they're like dial it I go dude I
use not gonna make it stop the minute
you know and you know when you're it's a
military system in medicine you're yes
sir
that's it I had a guy once sit up
older man much older and sort of
demented he's probably just nineties and
he he sits up he's just he was confused
and babbling low low and sort of
flailing and all of a sudden set up in
bed he looks at his family says I have
an appointment with Tom Smith at one
o'clock don't let me forget and then
went right back down and
well Tom Smith's been dead for a couple
years is the best friend one o'clock
this guy died Wow that crazy bizarre
yeah so coincidence I don't know
speaking with God I don't know to who
what video boy asked which celebrity
death that you worked with has affected
you the most death God they all affected
me a lot
really and differently so they get to
you when you of course yeah probably if
I had taken your children that of course
probably Rodney yeah
Rodney was one of the sweetest most
delight you he's rough around the edges
when he drank make no mistake about it
Dangerfield know Rodney King sorry and
and when he he died a cardiac death
again I got blame for that too I could
blame for everything he died a cardiac
death everybody yet it just too hurtful
even fell in a pool and drowned
yeah
how he died but he was just the most
just a really delightful human being
well and I remember I started funny I
was thinking of him the other day I
don't know why I was thinking about this
but I actually at one point put him in
charge of the unit because there was so
much chaos and I said I'm putting this
guy in charge and it made him feel
really good about just like a gentle
giant man just get to control buddies
very respectable but nobody screw with
him yeah did you feel like there was
some like it was the reason that did you
feel like maybe the reason that you know
what happened to Rodney King and those
events in his life like he was a perfect
candidate for that in a weird way like
do you ever for the beating yeah like
I'm not that anybody's Irv's to be
beaten but that he would there was
something about him that would be able
to use that as like it would come
through in a positive way afterwards
does it make sense like it would
influence and make change like yeah but
I think that's lucky because it was just
some guy with a video camera across the
street I've stood on that spot with
Rodney where that happened there's like
a Children's Museum there now and you
know the fact that he you know who said
can't we all get along that that was not
coach that's Ronnie there's a full-on
run I knew his mom and his family it's a
great guy now what but terrible caller
you know and when you're diseased you'd
do things you wouldn't otherwise do so
who is the most challenging celebrity on
on screen or off that you've had worked
with that is just I can't say about off
right right there have been a few but I
have sort of two answers to on-screen oh
crap I'm forgetting her name Mary the
the she's Mary Tyler Moore she was was
where I get my Jews get my juice every
morning member this know Carrie Anne
Carrie Anne Kari Ann Peniche oh there
you go yeah yeah she was tough but but
she was just tough you know behaviorally
and seven and I had ended up having good
and a lot of affection for her the
hardest overall of me was Jeff Conaway
yeah because he represents really why I
got out of treatment treatment which is
I got tired of fighting that
as my peers I would I would literally
have Jeff in no pain he would get up and
tap dance for me and two weeks later my
periods would put him back on opiates
and benzo days yeah and that's what he
died of of people putting him back he
was actually at one point in a nursing
home because that's the only way they
could safely give him that many meds and
nobody went this guy's a drug addict we
take him off please I thought I was
fighting fighting fighting fighting
fighting and they were just there and
sure killed him Wow and what do you
think is one of the biggest problems
facing you like human beings in medicine
today
human beings are Americans Americans
yeah
I'm just noticing and this is not a
medical thing per se right now well I
guess let me just say the medical thing
is people need to get used to the fact
that we're biological we need to teach
people about how biology works they have
just absolute magical thinking about
biological systems are infinitely
complex way more complex than anything
else you will deal with on earth
especially human biology and you need to
get a feel for how that works then
you'll stop falling for these stupid
diets and you'll stop thinking thinking
they're magical cures for cancer and
I'll yeah you will stop your simplistic
thinking we also have to realize we're
because we're biological we get sick and
we get sick and we die that needs to be
we gotta have to live with that right
it'll help us live better I suspect and
we'll be more compassionate towards
people that do get sick but that all
aside I feel like men are languishing
right now something's going on with
American men yeah we see it
statistically in middle-aged white men
killing themselves off the chain all of
a sudden also the incidence of all that
opioid as I consider that the same
problem they're effectively Tet all the
opioids in the man and the pain of
bah-bah-bah and then the young men are
sort of languishing and unhappy and not
motivated normally you can't find
passion getting subverted into Isis and
things I made this
something's not right and I and I can't
quite characterize it in a simple
sentence yet manhood manhood man right I
dunno I think that a hundred percent
what do you think it is
for me I really feel like that like
women have evolved more into like and I
don't want to say like an equal species
but equal in more ways than there's not
as much gender roles anymore okay
and so that make us sick because I think
as a man you need that difference to
have a lot of whatever like drives you
and inspires you I feel like that's kind
of where the yin and the yang was a
little bit and that that kind of woke
you up every day as a man and like but
but the woman created that by women like
trying to be I think more exactly like
men I think it's I think it drilled us
down somehow yeah it's like well then
what would want like what do i do who do
i what do i do as a man if I I think I
agree with you on I'm a super organized
with my thoughts all no no yeah you're I
agree with you on what they're
experiencing I'm not ready to lay it at
the blame at anything yet women
affirmative action whatever you want you
can blame a lot of places there's a lot
of stuff changing right below avenging
but why isn't it inspiring us so why
don't we we could just see you go well
fight that much harder than or goddammit
I'm gonna you know we have the opposite
but they're just roll over right and
then it's got to have something to do
with our parenting of the baby boomers
that's good as god is through such
interest we're doing but then why would
that translate in a middle-aged man yeah
right so so I'm all over the place with
it it's just something I'm thinking a
lot about maybe it's technology at all
figures in our limbic system is like
dying I think dying the technology and
the porn is too much wait till virtual
reality takes us out I'm trying to sell
porn I'm eight days clean right now for
you and I notice I'm noticing little
bitty changes in myself that are helping
and it's been a decade and now that
you'll have start to have feelings that
you don't expect that's the big thing
oh yeah I'm hoping for those so you will
a bunch of effect will emerge it you may
not like it you're feeling yeah that's
usually what you're covering for is
something that's kind of you're managing
with it yeah yeah sorry
no thank you he's probably shut off the
boat that I want to ask about a couple
people in the public eye now and your
thoughts yeah did you hear about the
Summa Blair's thing I did I felt bad for
her yeah what did you think it was a
combination she there was it was clearly
a medication
a substance reaction she got the message
good on her you know what I mean right
and how humiliating that just some crazy
[ __ ] like she's coming after me and she
was not she was not well that happens
when you drink and you wonder what
constellation of problems like woman's
dealing with but but the fact she's
taking off on a stretcher I mean how I
hope that's her bottom and I hope she
takes care of herself because that those
things end up being good sometimes and
and she did I mean exactly the right
thing she said this is this is not me
this is humanity I'm gonna take care of
this now let's see if she does is it a
sign of a problem well I mean if you're
getting carried out in this stretcher
yeah I mean if she is she being
mismanaged the doctor do that to her
it's possible is it a substance problem
and improper medicine or is it just the
substance or is there a personality
issue is there bipolar right yeah that's
some possibilities here so the fact
though that that she what I always look
for is not how sick people are look for
them to in seek treatment engage in
treatment right because we can do great
we can treat almost anything when people
are engaged right the conundrum always
getting people engaged in treatment
which is they don't want to right that's
the hard part
secondly ben affleck and allegedly what
do you think drunk what did you think
about that guy from boston that's
passionate about his team period and
really maybe didn't sleep well the night
before please everybody I guarantee you
lay off Ben Affleck a little bit what's
throwing a little bit I get that way
we're not young men here I and when we
miss some sleep or we travel that
happens naturally you get in
particularly you can't fire off of that
kind of a diatribe maybe allow call
maybe but yeah you know he is you know
he's a guy that's been treated for
addiction so V if it was related alcohol
he needs to take care of that but it's
not like he was wasted it's not like
this was man and did not in his right
mind right him why what to me it's more
about us with the matter with us that we
take whiff to pick that apart poor guy
yeah that makes good films yeah it was
cool it's nice to see first of all it
was nice to see a celebrity open up
about I can be like thank you that's
that should have been the reaction as
opposed to the Twitter Bob but you guys
you gotta take it down take them down
very quick to do that that's people that
is really that's the worst in humanity
why we don't see it as such it's human
sacrifice that's what that impulse is
throw me the volcano yeah and
lastly when you see us someone like
Taylor Swift who date's a lot in the
public eye and she dates different guys
and moves on and on what what comes to
your mind for that what do you think
whatever she is yeah Blake is there it's
like you don't know how much is
manufactured right we don't know truth
because she's pretty glossy that's true
yeah exactly us anything it's that kind
of serial stuff look looks like love
addiction yeah that's a one way of
conceptualizing that lovely diction yeah
so you're addicted to the idea of being
in love your your your get in deep fast
and you idealize the other person and
you have lots of fantasies attached to
that and then you can't quite get out
and then the person because you go so
deep so fast the other person feels like
it's clingy and the other person
sabotages and then the cycle repeats by
the way what is the strangest addiction
that you've ever come across you asked
me to remember things I see so much good
stuff I mean I've seen those shells were
like yeah it's so fun the weird stuff
I've seen is on those shows yeah one guy
felt like his ears for years and finally
could kind of lick it what he set out to
do the reality is mostly addiction I
dealt with his traditional gotcha I have
a question and this was from a friend of
yours associate when was the last time
you got roadhead was a couple months ago
fashioned roadhead yeah
was this in traffic I hope not like it
it'll speed no doubt for you okay what's
worse Jennifer have a great wife
medically speaking what's worse to be
texting while you're driving or be
getting roadhead while you're dragging
is way worse much harder you figure eyes
at the road you yeah chemicals though
and stuff when you're getting yeah yeah
well you if you can't control yourself
you're gonna do a self-assessment yeah
see I don't have a prostate anymore
right up prostate cancer all right
and so no fuss no mas with me that's
awesome
the kids put down those phones and open
up his mouth I have a question from
Renda Sweeney if you could strangle any
of the team-mom people who would it be
Pharaoh
Farah yeah sorry I'm sorry no she's not
awful
she's frustrating this is frustrating
she's not awful she's not awful I mean
she suffers believe me that when people
behave like that's because they're
suffering yeah right and and I feel bad
for her a lot but but she can be very
frustrating and then they the same
person I like Hera I like her too yeah
and she's a woman now I dealt with when
they were teenagers you know was there's
anybody who's that thirsty what do you
mean you know she's thirsty for that
attention it just really hurt but yeah
but it's her that's her job she has
embraced it and this is what she's gonna
do and she doesn't have other skills of
training and he's got a mom that
encourages her to do that stuff and her
dad that's kind of weirdly ambivalent
about it he's having a tough time
himself and and then she was led in by
people that she trusted and then feels
as though she was exploited and I really
get things weren't the way she intended
them because she's you know she's trying
to navigate through this crazy world
yeah I feel bad you're so good at
processes if you're like an early man
kind of you know like processing things
yeah the same person asks how can you
sit on a stage with Anand Lynn and not
want to know knock him the [ __ ] out Oh
Adam the boyfriend yeah look all these
how can you sit on stage with these I
have a deep affection for almost
everyone in that show and that is my
team mama and Maya now my job is to as a
clinician my job is always to empathize
with people and see their point of view
and to try understand their pain and
stuff and I've been with these kids a
long time and I do understand them I
what does frustrate me is people
expecting me to treat them I do a
one-hour talk show with where I explore
their lives and I offer myself as a
resource to them they all have my phone
number but I'm guide the eye at most I
will refer them to somebody guy that I
don't treat them and people out and so
for me to think why don't you do this
why'd you do that other than your
response hosting a talk fair enough but
I have some skills where I understand
how to navigate into the emotional
landscape and we get into it a little
bit and I try to kind of help a little
bit in the context of this talking we're
doing that is not treatment they know
it's not treatment I know the audience
doesn't know it's not treatment that's
bizarre to me I guess they get so used
to thinking that what dr. Phil is doing
is treatment right well the others yeah
that is natural it's not true that's the
opposite of that is reinforcing defenses
and these are like of course he refers
for treatment to right he goes already
of course yeah he's doing a good tell
the job he's doing his job on TV and
then he refers people for treatment do
you think he's actually ending up
helping getting people treatment I think
so I think so I mean I I bothers me if
he thinks he's doing treatment that
would be bad right right but I think he
knows what he's doing
yeah interesting um was there ever one
of the teen moms that like at obviously
because when you first start working
there were teens and they were adults
we're like you were like oh this is a
teenager this is a child but as they
grew they were obviously then they were
women they yes you went from like there
was no attraction that there was an
attraction one of them me attacked it no
it sounds almost almost like you were
saying that about your kids or something
yeah it sounds funny to me it made it
sound funny to you I understand right
but it's funny to me how you preface it
after they were out of their teens
children yeah yeah and and not only that
I I see them as who they are you know
and I mean they're not objects of
anything for me other than people who've
been really struggling and I've been
good enough to share their lives with
people and and they're a lot of them you
know you don't get pregnant 16 because
you don't have liabilities that's an
at-risk youth by definition 100% yeah
most of my neighbor who is pregnant
do you see do you see doctors who do
take advantage of people in weak states
for whatever reason I mean including you
know I look at I do believe there's a
problem with the prescribing and stuff
like that do you see people who like
alright you seem like a really good guy
and you have a little bit of power over
people when you are a doctor I read
about it and I hear about in the media
so I've never seen I never said I've
never seen I've seen people show bad
judgment they make bad calls and that
kind of stuff that I've never it's from
that's one of the things I remember
early my training I'm like oh my god my
peers I've never seen such a
well-meaning self-sacrificing group of
people Wow I mean I was like they're all
everyone that was my agent right there
you were all like whoa I gotta like
check myself all the time to make sure I
keep up with these guys
yeah that's really cool and I do want to
ask about the opera scene too okay I saw
the video which one the one on TMZ where
you're singing the national anthem at
Staples yeah like this yeah for five
minutes I thought is give me an opera
singer when I was like 2019 and I go to
like a big crowd or something like I was
going to and then I got off that train
wisely and got back into the sciences
yeah interesting then I always trained I
always did musical stuff she was like
singing home like are you seeing an
opera my son's a real musician a real
musician and so I'd like hand at the man
over to him okay mom was an opera singer
strangely entirely I grew up hating it
she wouldn't sing but she'd have this
stuff playing and stuff and and then all
of a sudden I found my way to it it's
weird
so do you sing opera in the shower
sometimes a little bit sounds better
there I'm just picturing well room the
first I was picturing the road head and
now I'm picturing the shower and all
together somehow
but really the car is more worth saying
every open road yeah I just think about
the prostate cancer thing at pcs or I'm
very involved with prostate cancer
Foundation which is having massive
breakthroughs in cancer treatment and
what we're doing with prostate cancer
it's going to affect many other cancers
so please check PCF out alright well
then that rats it wraps up around 2 you
have to pick a winner of said around oh
yeah I wasn't thinking they always
forget that yeah our conversation I am
can I can I abstain because you guys
asked very different and good questions
they're very different you can obtain
it's almost again unless you get to puta
puta head like you had relative value
it's not a fair we call that kind of
person more prepared there we go you add
some stuff to I know I know you did but
I think you were more prepared I am
looking at my notes no I know but he had
more the the question agree there we go
all right so for what that's already
that's alright okay
round 3 which is our mini competition
alright okay and so our specific mini
competition do we have a producer how
Isaacson is here today's have spoken so
our specific mini competition is dr.
drew here is going to give us symptoms
of a STD anyone I do whole series you
know do a couple and then we'll see Theo
and I have to guess what it is I'll do a
bunch of them okay okay all right good
you come in your partner's got gonorrhea
you haven't had sex with her she hasn't
been cheating what do you have come in
your partner has gotten come inside are
you coming with me come with me and
you're like I know what's gonna she has
gonorrhea and we have I we she and I
have not been having intercourse we've
not been having intercourse I promise me
of course doctors we already Leon
they're lying there live with it so I
assume all right but you not it let's
perfect idea of course you get around a
little bit yourself and you have
something so this guy has so well okay
I'll say yes you have something okay
what do you have the guy has the clap
where because she has the clap she has
gonorrhea
gonorrhea is the clap yeah chlamydia
know what clap is really gonorrhea class
I don't know I don't know a guy has oral
gonorrhea yes has no symptoms
oh so they know you have it what about
even bad breath Wow come to me you for
you you you were this coming to doctors
you hate going to doctors and you have a
rash on your palms
it's a very strange rash red blotchy
rash on your
and you've noticed some lymph nodes
swollen up on your arms are in there and
but the rash is fading so you you almost
didn't make your appointment so it's not
is it
it's not just friction from over
masturbation it's not it's on both hands
it's symmetric and it's a rash is a rash
may be a bit on your feet too okay okay
um both hands open your feet and it's
fading its fading and and maybe maybe
you're trying to remember and you think
maybe you got a sore on your penis but
it didn't hurt or and these it went away
it's no big deal so I didn't come in for
that I love that you're really playing
the part I love it
okay um it's I'll keep going yeah well
you discipline yes that's what it is yes
I knew it
whereas jancker was Sankar is a painless
ulcer that goes away
most guys most people don't kids the
ulcer occurs that uses the point of
contact
uh-huh goes away and then you get
secondary syphilis which is typically a
rash and the rest and there can become
a--'s there could be other things that
kind of developed and then that goes
away and then a certain percentage of
people get something called tertiary
syphilis where it gets into your wheel
spinal fluid and eat your brain oh so if
you meet a real dumb chick you could
have that or dumb boy all right so
that's one one Wow
do we have to be you guys are kind of
bring a woman in oh yeah this is in this
is not us by the way you've got a bad
yeast infection icky but her lymph nodes
are really Swan or grind they really
hurt and they bother and she feels kind
of tired and crappy and this has been a
it's useful the East Medicaid doesn't
seem to go away and just keeps going
burrowing it's bad oh oh I know this one
okay uh because I know someone who has
it I think they will it if she waited
long enough it would go away
right right this is um her boyfriend had
something because this had a red mark
that he kind of said
kind of his on his penis of bad memories
where the show has been you know he
don't really think anything of it but he
had the same thing when his lymph nodes
hold on let me take some no I know this
I know it I know exactly what it is and
it's gonorrhea
no [ __ ] easy why I know it is cuz it's
not like life-threatening no a chlamydia
no it's uh what a classics HPV no that's
the usually you don't know you have it
because that normal paps can cause warts
but all the people need to get their
vaccines for the HPV I've been chanting
about that for years and finally people
are coming around to that so yes prevent
cancer get your HPV vaccine sir this is
also a virus and people are struggling
to create a vaccine against it and it's
not rabies huh
it's herpes herpes that's all and yes
yes I was thinking of the mouth no but
that could be on the mouth because right
there I've been celebrities who have the
sores and stuff on it and then anything
all right herpes all right tide so we
need a tiebreaker we need to get one do
you want me to go obscure or do you know
obscure obscure probably I don't think
we know obscure yeah
I don't know much about vaginas in
general okay this is a try this you
won't know these I live in a tropical
area and I've got this shaggy ulcer on
my penis and these huge lymph nodes
developing and this ulcer anak kind of
way it is it is
I can't wait doesn't really hurt but it
kind of does but it's it looks like a
giant clam on my penis it's nasty look
at gout gangrene Jake right okay there's
got to be one more that we don't have
there obscure stuff that happens
we think here I like a little anal play
mm-hmm put that on a loop and I've
noticed these sort of skin tags around
my anus there and they they seem to get
beginning more anal warts there is this
girl in Nebraska Adam that's associated
with anal cancer too so everybody get
really yes Oh Margaret and then if you
are listening I didn't even tell her
about him but I saw him and you probably
need to get brushed up well what did you
do when you saw him I didn't say
anything you just went along with the
vaccine right away you can't really
check the mail for HPV you can't you can
if the warts develop obviously but
there's really no other way to check the
mail all right well Margaret and I'll
get checked out as well is there
anything that disgusts you um you know
I've seen terrible things in terms of
body fluids really bad sputum will get
to me you know coughing out of your
lungs stuff you can cuff about your legs
you really got portable things
that's gross looks like I mean this has
been on my mom's nose I'm driving around
thinking about you know honestly a
little bit of do you think I don't some
women have like an in jacket right is it
urine mostly I know it mostly not
necessarily but but someone had produced
some other fluids out of the Perrysville
gland right and it turns out the women
have a gland that sits over the urethra
that if you look at our microscope looks
just like a prostate gland which is what
produces our semen right and someone
would have more of that and they can
produce you know you can have the wind
you've been in the trenches much more
than I have so you know like the you
have you have OCD yes I do but I also am
gay so the women thing freaks me out
more than the germs actually how
interesting dr. drew thank you for
coming in here man no pun intended and
we can catch you obviously every week on
the atom and doctor five days a week
then HLN please support net zero or four
o'clock Pacific 7:00 Eastern and the
Doctor Who podcast and the diss live
podcast and I appreciate the Teen Mom
fans out there that are that are fans of
you guys because oh yeah that show has
had a dramatically positive impact
I knew whatever impact on teen pregnancy
and it has has it really they've had
they've published now a couple of
academic studies that show the higher
the viewership in a given community the
lower the teen promise here Wow and the
teen pregnancy rate in the country began
falling a rapidly the quarter that that
this show started airing and it's hit a
nadir now where it's lower than it's
been in the 1940s really that's crazy
way to go teens doctor thank you so much
about you appreciate my pleasure